i wanted to ask you something about the
stranger things season four production
schedule because i know it was a very
unique experience on that one so
what would you say is one unique pro of
filming season four something that's you
know better than ever
and then what's something that proved to
be more challenging that you had to
adjust to in order to overcome
i mean yeah so we started filming season
four
i don't even know when it was but it was
before the pandemic and then we had
we got like a month of filming done then
we had to stop
for i guess seven or eight months and
then we came back to work and things
were like completely different
so i think the real challenging part was
just adjusting to the
to the new the new rules and the the
regulations that were
in place on set that was a big
adjustment but yeah and i think we were
just all just so
grateful to be able to work and yeah
we've been working
working for a while now and and creating
something really amazing the scale of
the show just gets bigger and bigger
each year
um so yeah it's just been really
incredible
to see where they're going with the
storyline which it's really amazing this
year and just how the stakes are just
so much higher higher than they've ever
been